hallo und herzlich willkommen tsum
allerneusten und alle tollsten format
auf youtube wannen gedanken in diesem
format werde ich über alles sprechen was
mir so durch den kopf geht was ich
glaube euch mitteilen zu müssen und
vielleicht gibt's ja auch den ein oder
anderen das sogar gefällt mag ich mich
selbst man hört ja immer wieder
das wichtigste ist dass du dich selber
liebt dabei ist es einfach bei den
allerwenigsten so und vor allem in der
pubertät ja ich weiß
teenager hassen ist wenn man sie diese
schublade steckt aber ich kann mich noch
erinnern als ich zum alter von 13 bis 17
war wie viele selbstzweifel ich einfach
hatte ok heute wurde das durch eine
kümmert mich nicht einstellungen ersetzt
die glaube ich auch nicht so gesund ist
ihr solltet ihr nicht egal sein was
andere über dich denken ist es nicht
besser dass man sich quasi so gern hat
dass man nicht verstehen kann warum
andere schlecht über ihn denken dass es
so ein kompliziertes thema einfacher
wäre es wenn niemand irgendetwas
negatives über irgendjemanden sagt oder
dann kann es auch passieren dass wir
irgendwann alle einen haufen arschlöcher
sind die nur an sich selbst denken
quasi der antikommunismus jetzt aber
noch eine frage an euch ist selbst liebe
nicht irgendwie selbst verliebt also ist
es nicht im allgemeinen eine schlechte
eigenschaft weil damit gleich so etwas
wie egoismus oder so verbunden wird und
ist das dann der große fehler
warum es keiner schafft sich selbst
richtig toll zu finden weil das sich
selbst lieben eine nicht
gesellschaftlich anerkannte vorne gefühl
ist immer der gesellschaft
zu dienst wenn ich jetzt meine positiven
eigenschaften aufzählen würde müsste
könnte ich so lange darüber nachdenken
was ich sagen kann damit es nicht selbst
verlegt wird aber irgendwie selbst
sicher ist dass ich meine zum beispiel
finde ich mich halt echt witzig und auch
kreativ aber es gibt hunderte menschen
die nicht dieser meinung sind oder sich
sogar super ungünstig finden und wenn
ich jetzt negative dinge über mich
ausziehen sollte ich hätte ein ganzes
buch voll den sekunden besonders durch
youtube kommentare wie du hast
vorgegeben szenen die ich plötzlich
dinge an mir die ich vorher noch nie so
betrachtet habe und ja man muss kein
youtuber seinem im internet beleidigt zu
werden ich weiß und ist jetzt schon
wieder das internet daran schuld oder
doch die fashion magazine mit den
supermodels und den super super schöne
photoshop super gesichtern
ich weiß es muss ein flüchtling jetzt
schon die ersten kommentare was hast du
dir flüchtlinge glaubt ihr dass facebook
hat sich sich selbst nun ich meine wer
so viel hass gegenüber anderen hat muss
ja auch irgendwo liebe rein stecken
können oder aber davon auch schon wieder
ganz andere gedanken
ich gebe euch einen tipp als solche die
wandel und macht euch mal gedanken
darüber
ich meine vielleicht kommt der eine oder
andere auf die lösung wie man sich
selbst lieben kann
es wäre doch klasse und wenn euch dieses
video gefallen hat dann zeigst mir noch
mit dem daumen nach oben und wir sehen
uns beim nächsten video tschüss